[ BELLS TOLLING ]
YOU CAN HEAR SUBTLE INSTRUCTIONS
BEING GIVEN IN TERMS OF MOVING
THE CASKET ON TO THE --
>> BEARER PARTY WITH THE MOST
SENIOR GUARDS.
THE QUEEN'S COLONEL AND CHIEF.
THEY HAD A CENTRAL ROLE
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND THE
TEN PALLBEARERS FOUND FROM
FORMER THE PEOPLE THAT SORT OF
SERVED THE QUEEN THROUGHOUT HER
REIGN WHILE SHE WAS STILL ALIVE.
THREE OFFICERS, 53 RANK AND FILE
FROM EACH SERVICE WITH COLORS
DRAPED ACCOMPANIED BY BAND WITH
DRUMS DRAPED WITH MUFFLED TO BE
MOUNTED IN PARLIAMENT SQUARE AS
WELL AS THEY GO BY.
>> WE ALSO SEE PRINCE HARRY OF
COURSE THERE AND PRINCESS ANNE
WHICH IS REALLY -- NOW THE
SOUNDS.
LET'S LISTEN
.
THE BELLS WILL BE TOLLING ALL
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESSION.
PRINCESS ANNE, PART OF THE
PROCESSION, THE ROYAL FAMILY,
BEHIND THE CASKET.
BREAK FROM TRADITION BUT ALSO A
SIGN OF HER -- THE ROLE, THE
IMPORTANT ROLE, SHE HAS PLAYED
EVER SINCE THE QUEEN DIED.
>> I THINK SHE WILL GOING
FORWARD AS WELL.
I THINK CHARLES HAS REALLY DRAWN
HER IN TO ALL OF THIS.
SHE WAS THERE WHEN THE QUEEN
DIED AND NO ONE WILL EVER GET TO
TAKE THAT AWAY FROM HER POSITION
DURING THIS PERIOD OF MOURNING
THAT CONTINUES UNTIL THE END OF
THE DAY IN THE UNITED KINGDOM,
BUT ANOTHER WEEK FOR THE ROYAL
FAMILY.
SO, AHEAD OF THIS GROUP OF
SAILERS, YOU'LL SEE VARIOUS
MILITARY OFFICIALS.
>> LET'S JUST LISTEN TO THIS FOR
A MOMENT.
♪
>> WE CAN HEAR THIS IN OUR EAR
ON TELEVISION AND EARS BEHIND US
AS THIS PROCESSION COMES TO
WESTMINSTER ABBEY RIGHT NEAR
WHERE WE ARE.
LOOK AT THE FACES OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY, RICHARD.
YOU SEE THE KING, PRINCESS ANNE
ESCORTING THEIR MOTHER.
>> YES.
>> HER FINAL WALK.
>> YOU HAVE THE PROCESSION IN
THREE CARDS, THOSE FORWARD OF
THE GUN CARRIAGE, THE COFFIN ON
THE STATE GUN CARRIAGE OF THE
ROYAL NAVY ADORNED WITH THE
CROWN, THE SCEPTER AND THE ORB
AND THE ROYAL FAMILY AT THE REAR
OF THE CARRIAGE.
THE KING, THE PRINCESS ROYAL,
THE DUKE OF YORK AND THE EARL OF
WESSEX.
MARKING BEHIND THEM THE DUKE OF
SUSSEX AND THE PRINCE OF WALES,
PRINCE WILLIAM.
AND THEN, THE VICE ADMIRAL
LAWRENCE.
RICHARD, DUKE OF GLOUCESTER AND
THE EARL OF SNOW DHS DEN.
VERY CAREFULLY THOUGHT THROUGH
WHO IS STANDING WHERE.
THE ORDER OF PRECEDENCE AND
PROTOCOL DICTATING YOUR
POSITION.
>> DICTATING THE DAY.
YOU SEE OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU SAW
THEM MOVE IN AS THE GUN CARRIAGE
BEGAN TO MOVE, JUST THE
INCREDIBLE COORDINATION, THE
PERFECTION, AND YET THE HUMAN,
THE HUMANITY THAT WE'RE SEEING
OF THE FAMILY, OF KING CHARLES
WITH THAT SOMBER LOOK ON HIS
FACE OF SAYING GOOD-BYE TO HIS
MOTHER AND TAKING ON THE MANTLE
THAT HE WILL BE TAKING ON TODAY
IN A VERY REAL AND TANGIBLE WAY.
>> EXACTLY.
AND AGAIN IN HIS FIRST SPEECH HE
PLEDGED TO CONTINUE IN HER
FOOTSTEPS AND HER LEGACY.
AND IT IS REMARKABLE TO SEE THIS
BECAUSE WE HAVE SAID IT BEFORE
AND WE HAVE TO SAY IT AGAIN,
THERE LITERALLY IS NO OTHER
MODERN EQUIVALENT TO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING.
THIS IS THE KIND OF TRADITION,
THE MAJESTY, THE POMP, THE
CIRCUMSTANCE, ALL THOSE WORDS
THAT REALLY APPLY ONLY TO THIS
KIND OF VERY, VERY BRITISH
CEREMONY.
AND THE QUEEN HERSELF HAS
CONFERRED THIS SLIGHTLY
INTANGIBLE BUT REAL LEGITIMACY
ON THE PROCESS FOR THE LAST 70
YEAR.
AND THAT IS WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING AT THIS MOMENT AND
SO VITAL AND WHY PEOPLE HAVE
COME OUT IN THEIR HORDES TO
WATCH THIS.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE SOME 2
MILLION PEOPLE EXPECTED IN THE
CITY, INCLUDING IN THE PARKS
AROUND US, GREEN PARK, HYDE
PARK, ST. JAMES' PARK, THEY'RE
PUTTING UP HUGE SCREENS ALL OVER
THE CITY, ALL OVER SCOTLAND,
WALES, NORTHERN IRELAND AND KEY
PLACES.
THERE WILL BE CINEMAS, THERE
WILL BE PUBS OPEN FOR EVERYBODY
WATCHING THIS AND NOT TO MENTION
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
AND AGAIN I THINK THE QUEEN IS
LOVED BECAUSE IN THIS MODERN
WORLD SHE WAS ABOUT OTHERS.
SHE WAS ABOUT SERVICE.
SHE REALLY PERFORMED, HER
GRANDMOTHER, QUEEN MARY ONCE
SAID, WE ARE NEVER TIRED AND WE
ALL LOVE HOSPITALS.
IN THAT ONE PHRASE SHE SUMMED UP
WHAT THE ROLE OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY WAS.
AND THE QUEEN PLAYED THAT ROLE
TO THE VERY END, NEVER
COMPLAINING, NEVER EXPLAINING.
AND AGAIN THIS IS ANOTHER WITH
HER FAMILY THERE, AND BRINGING
IT ALL SORT OF TO THIS, YOU
KNOW, PUBLIC BUT ALSO FAMILY
CLOSURE, SHE SAID OVER AND AGAIN
THAT I HAVE TO BE SEEN TO BE
BELIEVED.
THIS HAS TO BE SEEN IN ORDER FOR
THE PEOPLE TO BELIEVE.
SO, EVERYTHING ABOUT HER 70
YEARS WAS ABOUT SHOWING HERSELF
IN PUBLIC, NOT HER EMOTIONS, NOT
HER OPINIONS, BUT HERSELF.
THE BRIGHT COLORS THAT SHE WORE,
THAT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT.
IT WAS TO SHOW HERSELF, NOT JUST
TO THE PEOPLE BUT WHEN SHE WAS
IN A ROOM OF MALES, ALL
SURROUNDED BY MALE LEADERS, MALE
COMMONWEALTH HEADS, MALE
POLITICIANS AT THE G7s, AT THE
YOU KNOW -- ALL THESE DIFFERENT
COMMONWEALTH MEETINGS THAT SHE
HAD.
AND I SPOKE TO HER -- ONE OF HER
FEMALE PRIME MINISTERS, THERESA
MAY, WHO SAID SHE WAS AN
INSPIRATION FOR WOMEN AND SHE
WAS SUCH A REAL PERSON WHO KNEW
SO MUCH AS WELL.
>> AND SUCH A TIE THROUGH
HISTORY.
AS YOU SEE THE GUN CARRIAGE,
QUEEN VICTORIA'S GUN CARRIAGE.
THE CROWN, WHICH OF COURSE WAS
ORIGINALLY MADE FOR THE
CORONATION OF THE QUEEN'S
FATHER, KING GEORGE.
ALL OF THIS TANGIBLE CONNECTION
TO HISTORY, HISTORY, OF COURSE,
THAT GOES BACK 1,000 YEARS WHERE
YOU ARE, CLARISSA, OUTSIDE
WESTMINSTER ABBEY, AS THIS
PROCESSION IS MAKING ITS WAY TO
WHERE YOU ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> JUST AN EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT,
ERIN.
YOU CAN SEE THE HURST BEING
PULLED ON THE GUN CARRIAGE THAT
PULLED ALSO WINSTON CHURCHILL
AND QUEEN ELIZABETH II'S FATHER,
KING GEORGE VI.
I THINK EVERYBODY STANDING HERE
CAN'T HELP BUT TO FEEL MOVED,
NOT JUST BY THE EXTRAORDINARY
BEAUTY OF THOSE BAG PIPES, BUT
BY THIS EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT,
TRADITION, HISTORY, PLAYING OUT
IN FRONT OF US IN A WAY THAT WE
HAVE NOT SEEN IN OUR LIFE TIMES.